"
I'M JAKE TAP
AND IN THI WITH
PRESIDENT  R
LEAVING CALIFORNIA WHEERECE OAS
STOPCAMPAIGNWING.
MORE 9 TI IN R
ERHIS YEAR HAV MILLION ACRES ST
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES B
PREN ER JOE BIDEN COULD NOTBIDE
NEED H VIEW TO THE.
PRP, CONVE T B BLAMING CIF S  I
CONTINUINGTE EVEN OU AS
TO
PRESIDENT TRT FORESTSIAL, AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PUSH CE IS STW
TREND MAKE OUR
BUT ALSO O WINRS WARMER ASIFORED
THINK IT'S NG.
>> IT'LLRTH.
AGREED WITH U.
>> I'TCE
>> F ONE MATTER DEATHRESIDENT
UMACING IGNORES THE SCE
CL Y AT
S  SAVIRUS PANDEMI  AOR IN ATAN
FEW MA SIGHT.
D HOLDING
RALLY WASNG LOCAL
RESTRICTIONS NEVAS GUIDANCE GIV
SENSE.
AS T U.S. SS THAN
OWORLD'S TI0%ON
DE TCIAL STATISTICS
AIOTHER W NNNOBTAINED A NEW RECH
PRESIDENT TRUM MONTH ATODA INSI
CNN'S KAITLAN COLLINS REPORTS.IF
YADGEING THE WCOT TRUMP MADE ARI
CALIFORNIA TO ASSESS T AFTER
FORGE SIL
DEVASTATION HE'S BLAMED ON MANA.
>> THERE HAS BE GOOD STRONG FOR
BEENKI FOR THREE YEARS.
>> Repr: IA GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSM
T DAGO,ONLY TRUMP'S O
AN>> FALL DOWN
THS  VERY DR
THEY BECOME REALLY LIKE A MATCH
STICK.
AL
WHEN YOU HAVE YEARS OLEAVES, E
URNING FOSSIL FUELSHAT HELONGERG
IS
IN CALIFORNIA? YOU'LL HAVE TO A.
I DON'T WANT TO STE ON HIS ASE
DO,RENCE
OPIOE RES T FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE OE
ARSONI IN T E, WHY ANYONEERPSEF
VICOMING AFTER HE A
RALLY W THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
INDOORYESTERDAY, BLATANTLY
DEFYIN NEVA
ORDER LIMITING INDOORS
TO PEOPLE.IENCEEN
WEGMASKS,
MOCKEDHE RNOR'S
RESTRICTION.
>> AND IF THE GOVERNOROM HE SHOL
WAY.
>> RteD THE LAS REVIEW JOURNAL
LI APPLY TO
AND HE WASN'T WORRIED
9 OME ROOM.
NO,CE MORE CONCERN AUTter: THE N
R AWOODWAOWHE PAN HIS RE-ELEC
THINK THEUS
SERECONY? OH, SURE B
RELATED, AS YOU KNOW.
>>
>> Rep ALSOODRD'VBEOV
DESPITE WHAT DY FAUCI
LDPPHATAS ONGOID  LIV JAKE J. W
ATINOS F EVENT.
AS PLSE G JOE
BIDEN OUT WITH THAT
BUT I WANT YOU TT THE HERE THE
GO HOST THISVE IN THE ROOM.
SEE HOW MANYHARE ARE LY THEY AR
TOGETHER.M COUNTED 500 CHAIRSTH
OF COURSE, IT'S UNCLEAR YET IF
ALL OF THEM ARE GNG BUT IT JUST
THROWING THESE-19
PRD
BASICA
>> AND W KNOW VIRS STRUCK M
LATINO AFRICAN-AMERICANS DISPRO.
JOINING MES
CALIFORNIA AND THERGISTORY H
THEESUST
CONED.
ANTRUMP TODAYOCUSEDREST MTION FF
F PRO
YOU  TOUTED EFFORESTAGKEIE T
WILDFIRES., IS THERE ANY TRUTH
THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING HERE?
>> CERTAINLY THERE IS.NEED TO M
TS BETTER.Y THERE ARES
THAT CAN BE DONE
BU I NOTICE DIDTHATNG
TOT' YRE TO UP A FUNDING
MECHANISM R U.S. FOREST
SERVICE THAT ALLOWS TOGE THE
MONEY.
PREVIOUSLY, ALL THE MONEY W  FI
BUT THE ISSUE ISR, BIGGER
THAN RAKING THE
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TOTEC
N1990s, AT TH
DEPARTMENT OF INTR
N-UP TOYO CN  STUDIED
TT W
WE PCT EXACTLY WHAT IS
HAPPENING TODAY WITH RRICANES,
WITH SUPERORITH FIRES.
W
IE
HERE WE ARE 22 YEARS  PRESI DEN
TH DANGER ONLY HE'S AGE
TO OUR
>> ALSO,SSMAN, GAVIN
NEWSOM POINTED OUT T
A E THIS
FEDE  A
NOE STATE LANDT, DOES AT OF
MANAGEMENT OF THEES? AOMAGO,
I'VE BEEN TALKING ABO FEDERRESTE
HAVE A NEWISM I
WE DO NEED TO IN THE FORESTS.
AND THEITY OF
FORESTS INIF
FEDERAL.
BUT THE OCCURRING NOT
ONLY IN THE FOREST OCCURRING ON
PRIVATE ND THEY ARECUIN ES, NLY
TIT IS DECTED
CLIMATE
WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT
SIMPLY T ACCEPT THE
RESPONLI HTHANK GOD BIDEN MADE
GARCETTI WASHE
UN
O HIS
UMP RESPONDS DISASTERS IN
REPUBLTE
E DOES WHEN THE DE EA
STATES.
TAKE A>> ANDROM ID GET ASATTENT
TOAP BUTUR
BEINANS,O BE OR>> DU THAT,ESID
>> LL, WE CERTAINLY KNOWSI PAYI
ARE INPL SWING
THCALIFORNIA,YES,
WE DO NEEDELP.EE ASSISTANC
TEROES
FORTUNATELY,TO RECOGNIZE THATST
NATION  INDEPENDENT,
WHOMEVER, SWING OR NOT, ALL
HURTING MONEY.
SO THE HEROE WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATELY NOT IN HER
INHE TO
THE MONEY THAT THESE LOCAL
GOVERNMENEED, NOT JUST
SUSTAIN THE FIREFIGHO
ALL OF THE OTHEIGIN THE ST O THN
EARLIER TODAY J AHEAD OF THE
ID
AND THERK DIFNC
LOOKING TO
FUTURE PROTECTINGME OF CLIMATETS
THAT THEREN EXISTS SUCH APROBLEN